julian an diesem tag wo wir all das
jetzt berichten müssen was geht jeder
durchs herz
wir haben hier gibt es um vieles durchs
herz nach zu vielen jahren in
afghanistan ja das ist natürlich für
alle die den krieg dort erlebt haben und
gelebt haben welche hohen preis so viele
menschen dort bezahlt haben deutsche
amerikaner unter afghanen um freiheit
und demokratie in dieses land zu bringen
wo das zumindest freizeiten von
terroristen da nun zu sehen was in
diesen stunden passiert der rückfall
nicht nur in die barbarisch
islamistische steinzeit sondern auch in
das zeitalter des terrors das ist
unendlich bitter mir geht aber vor allem
durch den kopf dass wir da einen
bemerkenswerten eine bemerkenswerte
wiederauferstehung von jesus offenbar
erlauben dass es erleben und das ist das
nächste debakel für joe biden aber auch
mit für die bundesregierung die ja auch
mit gegen dieses gekämpft hat und wenn
auch nicht in herausragende rolle in
syrien und in im irak was wir erleben
ist der wiederaufstieg einer
terror-organisation die eigentlich sieg
war und joe biden hat es mit seinem hals
über kopf abzug flankiert von seinen
verbündeten unter anderem unsere
bundesregierung nicht nur geschafft
afghanistan zurück ins chaos zu stürzen
die taliban wieder zu beleben die
taliban zu den best ausgerüsteten
taliban zu machen die es jemals gegeben
hat mit frischen waffeln frische
munition frischem gerät zwischen
fahrzeugen hubschrauber und flugzeuge
und so weiter sondern er hat das so
scheint es heute abend auch geschafft
die terror organisation dieses
wiederzubeleben die natürlich dieses
diesen failed state afghanistan für sich
beanspruchen will und da muss man sich
nichts vormachen zur operationsbasis
machen wird für anschlagswellen wie wir
sie in den düstersten tagen der letzten
jahre erlebt haben wie zb in paris beim
anschlag blatter klar wie zb in brüssel
das ist das was es will und heute abend
hat die offensive nicht nur gegen
afghanistan begonnen sondern gegen
europa gegen den westen gegen uns alle
und daran schuld ist amerikaner
präsident joe biden und daran schuld
sind seine verbündeten zu denen auch
unsere regierung gehört die afghanistan
dieses lang für das für 20 jahre
gekämpft haben
ungeordnet und chaotisch sind
schlimmsten terroristen dieser welt
wieder in die hände übergeben hat jetzt
erwarten wir ja in wenigen minuten die
rede von joe biden von diesem mann auf
dem so viele hoffnungen lag was
erwartest du dir von dieser rede
für mich lag die hoffnung auf joe biden
weil joe biden der vizepräsident von
barack obama war der
mit für die größten schrecklichsten
verschiebung der gewichte in der welt
verantwortlich ist obama der präsident
der nicht eingegriffen hat als präsident
das hat in syrien sein eigenes volk
vergast hat präsident obama dazu geguckt
hat beim kometenhaften aufstieg wladimir
putins in der welt der dem einmarsch der
krim dem einmarsch in der ost ukraine
niemand hat eine so verheerende
außenpolitik betrieben wie barack obama
an der außenpolitik von barack obama
leitet die welt bis heute und joe biden
hatte angekündigt die konsequent
fortzusetzen insofern ist das was wir da
gerade erleben wie obama die neuauflage
in möglicherweise noch schrecklicher
form insofern habe ich auch keinerlei
erwartungen an joe biden heute abend
oder an seine rede da ist auch nicht
mehr viel zu erklären das ist das größte
außenpolitische
verteidigungspolitische debakel der
amerikanischen geschichte mindestens
seit dem vietnamkrieg und ich glaube das
was wir dort erlebt haben elf oder zwölf
tote us marines das sind die toten von
joe biden das sind die soldaten die zur
beiden dort an diese mauer geschickt hat
um das debakel auszubaden was er selber
angerichtet hat und ich glaube das hat
implikation seine präsidentin das hat
durchaus das potenzial seine
präsidentschaft zu zerstören entweder
den ruf seiner präsidentschaft dieser
dieser diese blutflecken werden für
immer auf seiner präsidentschaft kliem
ich glaube aber die lage entwickelt sich
da gerade so dramatisch dass das
durchaus das potenzial hat die
präsidentschaft von joe biden in eine so
tiefe krise zu stürzen dass sie auch
schon früher enden könnte wir warten auf
die rede von joe biden war für 23 uhr
deutscher zeit angekündigt verzögert
sich offenbar ein bisschen du hast
gerade auch gesagt du gehst davon aus
weder als es für möglich dass seine
präsidentschaft mit dem heutigen tag
noch an schussfahrt gewinnt dass wir
heute einen seiner schwärzesten punkt in
dieser präsidentschaft auch erleben wir
hatten zuvor den professor wolffsohn bei
uns in der sendung der auch vor neuen
terroranschlägen hier in europa und
speziell auch in deutschland gewarnt hat
gesagt hat wir müssen eigentlich noch
mal überlegen wie wir überhaupt über das
ganze thema islamismus neu nachdenken
die sicherheitsstruktur verändern was
muss da aus deiner sicht am
dringlichsten passieren
also noch mal kurz zu joe biden joe
biden ist immer zu spät zur reinen sein
reden man wünschte sich der wirbel in
afghanistan abzug mal zu spät gewesen da
war deutlich zu früh zu zum thema
aufstieg des islamismus dazu wäre so
bitter viel zu sagen sicher ist jeder
islam ist auf der welt fühlt sich durch
das was in afghanistan sieht niemand den
westen mit dem schwanz zwischen den
beinen über einem geprügelten
flüchtenden und vertreiben kann
jeder der das sieht fühlt sich natürlich
ermutigt und fühlt sich natürlich
bestärkt in dem glauben dass der westen
und der art wie wir leben unter druck
und unter terror zusammenbrechen wird
das ist eine gefährliche botschaft an
alle islamisten auf der welt die
gefeiert wird von allen islamisten auf
der welt und natürlich werden diese
müssen auf der ganzen welt und auch in
deutschland das zum anlass nehmen ihre
[Musik]
geisteskranken ideen wieder verstärkt
durch gewalt durchzusetzen wir
deutschland sind ihm in keiner weise
gewachsen wir haben es während der anti
israel demonstration vor allen dingen
wochen gesehen da hat sich auch durchaus
beschleunigt und befeuert durch die
flüchtlingskrise ein sehr junges sehr
radikales sehr islamistisches milieu in
deutschland nicht gebildet aber durchaus
verstärkt was als rückzugsraum für
mögliche anschläge dienen kann dieses
milieus in keiner weise von unseren
sicherheitsbehörden durchdrungen und ich
sage wenn wir in den nächsten jahren
nicht unseren inlandsgeheimdienst
verfassungsschutz mit ganz starken und
einsteigen kompetenzen ausstattung und
befugnissen ausstatten gegen genau
dieses milieu vorzugehen dieses milieu
zu durchdringen ähnlich wie das zum
beispiel in israel ist dann werden wir
in deutschland über jahre und jahre eine
die stabilisierung unserer
sicherheitslage erleben wie wir uns das
heute noch überhaupt nicht vorstellen
können denn der geist ist da die leute
sind da der wille ist da und jetzt ist
auch noch die propaganda und die mittel
anschläge durchzuführen die fähigkeiten
die gibt es seitdem syrien krieg in
diesem millionen diesen kreisen auch auf
jeden fall wenn wir uns als staat nicht
darauf vorbereiten dann werden wir einen
zeitalter der islamistischen terror
anschläge leben und wir werden an die
heutige nacht als die wieder
geburtsstunde von asus und den auftrag
zu diesen anschlägen zurückbringen es
ist zynisch weil joe biden und wir
warten immer noch auf den beginn seiner
rede ja mit diesem abzug einig den kampf
gegen terror beenden wollte und jetzt
muss man ja sagen an den kampf gegen ist
zwar nicht beenden das ist der
entscheidende punkt der kampf gerhard
airport ist nicht genau es damit heute
toll was genau eine neue runde kann man
sagen fast nochmal gegangen bzw 1 einen
neustart meine erwartung ist es
eigentlich ausgeschlossen aus deiner
sicht dass es möglicherweise noch mal
eine neue militärische intervention in
afghanistan auch gibt um genau dieses
terror nest wieder sozusagen
auszuräuchern peter neumann hat das ja
eben schon sehr klug analysiert klug wie
immer kann man an dieser stelle einmal
sagen der amerikanische krieg in
afghanistan wird sich vor allem auf
spezialkräfte und drohten schläge
beschränken für die braucht man aber
eine operationsbasis und die braucht man
einen ausgangspunkt man braucht orte von
denen man auf operationen aufbricht man
braucht orte an denen man von denen aus
man
geheimdiensterkenntnisse sammelt all das
war bis vor wenigen wochen bis zu
arbeiten dass auf diese art und weise
her geschenkt hat die infrastruktur die
in kabul noch erhalten weil die
us-botschaft sie dort für rund eine
milliarde dollar gebaut worden ist eine
geheimdienst festung kann man zu sagen
mit der angestoßenen cas station all das
jetzt in den händen der taliban
weil joe biden leider vergessen hat dass
man
dieses land nicht einfach so
zurücklassen kann und übersehen hat dass
dieses land schon immer taliban geprägt
war und übersehen hat dass der kampf
gegen den terror eben niemals endet
sondern so ähnlich ist wie ein
polizeieinsatz entweder unterdrückt man
terroristen dann haben sie weniger
möglichkeiten zu operieren oder man
lässt den freiraum dann machen sie das
was terroristen am besten können nämlich
terroranschläge und genau das wird
wieder passieren
ihr wurde das land zurückgelassen
beschreibung das einmal genau an was
glaubst du wird ua sie nun einen
kommenden wochen und monaten entwickeln
das land wurde zurückgelassen
indem man sich selber eingeredet hat und
das über jahre ich habe es als reporter
selber viele jahre begleitet man könnte
den afghanen die dass diese übergabe der
sicherheitsverantwortung in
verantwortung das war die einigermaßen
schwachsinnige formulierung unserer
regierung dafür jeder der in afghanistan
unterwegs war jeder journalist jeder
geheimdienstler jeder soldat jeder
entwicklungs hälfte wusste es gibt gar
keine afghanische sicherheitskräfte ja
es gibt menschen die tragen ihre uniform
der afghanischen sicherheitskräfte die
begreifen sich aber nicht als
afghanischer sicherheitskräfte als
soldaten des landes sondern als
angehöriger ihre familien uniform die
dafür halt eben auch noch sollte
bekommen und zugang zu waffen und zugang
vielleicht ein bisschen macht aber
afghanischer sicherheitskräfte hat es
nie gegeben das hat auch jeder gewusst
und man hat einfach aus politischen
gründen wie in diesen einsatz
fortzuführen behauptet es gäbe sie und
dann absurde weise so gehandelt als gäbe
sie und passiert ist genau das was
journalisten die afghanistan gecovert
haben seit jahren und jahren die rasante
zur der rasante zusammenbruch der
sicherheitsstrukturen im land und die
übernahme durch die taliban und ich muss
sagen was mich am meisten entsetzt weil
es auch so erschütternde weise zeigt die
politik manchmal funktioniert das auch
unsere politiker unsere bundesregierung
unsere kanzlerin die 16 von 20 jahren
afghanistan-einsatz verantworten auf
ihre eigenen märchengeschichten reinfall
die sie sich gegenseitig erzählt haben
dass sie sich so lange erzählt haben
afghanistan hätte einer mehr obwohl auch
die wussten dass das nicht stimmt dass
ich so lange erzählt haben dass sie es
irgendwann tatsächlich geglaubt haben
und versucht haben diesen nicht
vorhandenen sicherheitskräften die
verantwortung für afghanistan zu
übergeben das muss ich sagen ist eine
bittere lektion in der kraft von politik
nicht nur die bürger sondern auch sich
selbst zu belügen
du sprichst die rede der kanzlerin auch
von gestern an die ja gesagt hat ja
hinterher ist man natürlich immer
schlauer wir hatten verschiedene andere
politische gäste den ganzen tag über bei
bild live aber gerade auch in der
sendung auffällig ist dass die sich alle
um eine frage drücken nämlich wie
künftig auf solche krisen auf den terror
muss die meisten politikerinnen und
politiker sagen ja es muss jetzt
aufgeklärt werden was in der
bundesregierung falsch gelaufen ist das
ist natürlich vollkommen richtig aber
wir müssen ja auch nach vorne schauen
wir müssen schauen und gucken und du
hast es gerade auch beschrieben was in
den nächsten wochen im nächsten monaten
in den nächsten jahren auf der welt
passiert möglicherweise nicht nur in
afghanistan sowie muss eine strategie
des westens der amerikaner zusammen mit
den europäern vielleicht auch
deutschland als führungsmacht aussehen
um terror nester auch rechtzeitig
bekämpfen zu können
also für eine strategie zusammen mit den
europäern wäre es erst mal schön wenn
das europäer überhaupt gebe in der
sicherheits- und verteidigungspolitik
und auch bei den geheimdiensten
es gibt da einige nischen kompetenzen
einige geil dienste die in manchen
dingen gut sind aber es gibt in europa
in keiner weise einer geheimnis
architektur die man mit der in den usa
vergleichen kann außer in großbritannien
wir sind
schwächliche weicheier wenn es um unsere
eigene verteidigung geht wir sehen uns
im moment europa mit 500 millionen
einwohnern ist nicht in der lage den
flughafen von kabul zu halten und unsere
eigene leute da rauszuholen europa hat
keine europa hat keine verteidigungs
infrastruktur insofern brauchen wir auch
keine gemeinsame strategie mit den
amerikanern terroranschläge in europa
werden verhindert indem die amerikaner
und vorhersagen dass terroranschläge
geben soll die das für uns aufgeklärt
haben es gibt da überhaupt nicht die
infrastruktur die unser unser angemessen
und würdig wäre und wenn man dann in
zukunft lektion trotzdem also erst
einmal das was die kanzlerin gesagt hat
hinterher ist man immer schlauer ist es
muss noch mal so klar sagen eine
absolute unverschämtheit und wirklich
eine beleidigung der intelligenz und
auch sehr vielen menschen die ihr über
afghanistan berichtet haben alle leute
beim bnd alle leute weil bei der
bundeswehr die ich kenne die jemals in
sozialen situation war der kanzlerin
direkt oder indirekt um die lage in
afghanistan zu berichten habe immer
genau dieses dieses schreckensszenario
prophezeit die waren alle vorher
schlauer die kanzlerin hat nur nicht auf
sie gehört jetzt so zu tun als hätte ist
das alles nicht gegeben ist wie gesagt
auch eine beleidigung des dienstes all
der leute die dort leben riskiert haben
um die kanzlerin darüber zu informieren
was in dem land los ist und das gilt für
geheimdienstes gilt für soldaten es gilt
aber auch für journalisten
die sie nie hat wahrnehmen wollen wenn
es darum geht was macht was lernt man
daraus für die zukunft
terroristen sind kriminelle schlimmster
sorte politischer sorte und maria sorte
und was macht man mit kriminellen man
bekämpft sie das ist alles was man mit
terrorismus machen kann und zwar immer
das kann man dann als faul bezeichnen
der ewig dauert und man kann das
natürlich politisch auch sehr gut nutzen
sagen wollen wir diese ewigen kriege das
ist ungefähr so als wollen wir wirklich
für immer polizei auf der straße haben
ja natürlich wollen wir für immer
polizei auf der straße haben und ja
natürlich wollen wir
sicherheitsstrukturen die für immer
gegen terrorismus kämpfen denn die
alternative dazu ist nicht dass
terroristen irgendwann als auch einsehen
wenn wir alle mit auch von sondern dass
die busse in berlin in die luft jagten
das ist das ziel von terrorismus und
deswegen ist die strategie gegen
terrorismus nicht nation building nicht
state building nicht wohnen worden
sondern terroristen töten und zwar dort
wo sie ihr haupt erhebt das ist die
strategie gegen terrorismus zu der ist
aber eigentlich nur amerika bereit und
das vereinigte königreich bereit
deutschland ist dazu nicht bereit
deutschland führt debatten darüber ob
wir amerika vielleicht weil hier irgend
eine satellitenschüssel steht zu oft
dabei helfen terroristen gezielt durch
drohnen in pakistan afghanistan und so
weiter auszuschalten deutschland ist in
keiner weise in der lage das zu
verteidigen was wir sind was wir lieben
und was wir leben und das sieht man
gerade auf bittere weise bei diesem
debakel am flughafen von kabul wenn die
kanzlerin hat gesagt mit dem heutigen
tag ist die luftbrücke verändert sie hat
aber auch versprochen werde sich kümmern
um die menschen also auch um die
ortskräfte also die menschen die
jahrelang dem westen die deutschland
dabei geholfen haben bei diesem
gescheiterten versuch frieden in das
land zu bringen wie groß war die so ist
die hoffnung für die menschen die jetzt
in afghanistan feststecken man wird sich
um diese menschen kümmern man hat ihnen
ja schon versprochen sich um sie zu
kümmern und jetzt stehen sie am
flughafen und werden von
selbstmordattentätern unterschiedlicher
couleur die luft gesprengt das
versprechen dass hier ganz eindeutig
gebrochen worden und das versprechen
dass man sich um sie kümmern wird
nachdem abgezogen ist also ich glaube
nicht dass das noch irgendjemand auf der
bread bereit ist zu glauben während die
menschen da bist du dich löcher in ihrem
eigenen blut stehen nachdem sie uns
einmal vertraut haben man wird sich um
sie kümmern sie sind zurück gelassen das
kapitel ist beendet und vielleicht
schaffen wir es noch für eine handvoll
entwicklungshilfe millionen den einen
oder anderen symbolischen
afghanischen helfer aus afghanistan frei
zu kaufen aber die menschen die uns dort
geholfen haben sind zurückgelassen
worden und zwar von allen verbündeten
die dort gekämpft haben das versprechen
ist gebrochen bevor es gegeben wurde
[Musik]